hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me so of course i've made a lot of dune
content on this channel but recently
i've been doing shorter videos for
people that might have seen the doom
movie but have not read the books just
to give those people some information
about what is going on we've talked
about why there's no robots in the
series we've talked about the politics
of dune we've talked about the emperor
and the beanie jesuit sisterhood now
it's time to get into what exactly paul
atreides saw in his visions that freaked
him out so badly now the book refers to
this as the terrible purpose and paul
actually begins to sense this very early
on in the novel paul atreides was bred
by the benny jesuit sisterhood as a tool
of control they have spent centuries
doing the groundwork and preparing the
universe for the coming of their quizets
hadorak and on arrakis their myths and
legends very easily took root because
the fremen were descended from the zin
sunni wanderers who before they got to
arrakis had been oppressed chased from
planet to planet never finding a true
home a culture born from this type of
society the bini jesuit knew were extra
susceptible to legends about a savior
messiah figure who would free them from
oppression so after being shifted from
planet to planet facing oppression on
every planet and after being oppressed
by the empire and the harkonnens
brutally for the past
nearly a century here comes paul
atreides who seems to fit the myths and
legends exactly when people truly
believe that a person is god whatever
that person says becomes the will of god
and because
god is realized in an actual form
the proof of his existence constantly
reinforces itself this is fertile ground
for fanaticism and that's exactly what
paul is seeing in his visions paul wants
to gain vengeance for house atreides but
in doing so
he kinda has to let the fremen believe
he is a god and when the fremen fight
for him they're not just fighting for
another leader they're fighting for a
messiah any war that the freeman might
fight in the name of paul atreides is a
holy war in allowing the freeman to
believe he is god paul will release a
fanatic religion onto the universe a
religion that will seek to convert all
non-believers they will be armed with
the certainty that their god paul
atreides is the one true god the one
true messiah and all those who
disbelieve cannot join in the kingdom of
heaven and once a fanatic religion like
this is unleashed it cannot be undone it
cannot be controlled it has momentum of
its own which goes beyond the mortal man
paul the trees paul is seeing a war rage
on and on in his name endless death in
his name unstoppable and totally outside
of his control a curious thing that the
movie does is that you can see when paul
is seeing these visions in the movie
that they disturb him incredibly and
even blames the benny jesuit sisterhood
and his mother for doing this to him and
yet at this point in time these visions
are not set in stone paul sees possible
futures it's important to note however
that at the end of the movie jessica
wants paul off of the world paul
actively makes the choice to stay on
arrakis full well knowing that the path
for atreides vengeance leads to an
unstoppable holy war he actively makes
that decision the fact that this is
shown explicitly in the movie shows us
that paul is kind of a great character
he's not the typical disney protagonist
that's perfect in most ways he's highly
skilled highly trained and yet fallible
and certainly not a messiah as many of
the freemen already believe frank
herbert writer of the original dune
series famously stated that he wrote the
dune series as a warning against
charismatic leaders he firmly believed
that when people threw their faith
behind a leader blindly it led to
catastrophe and that is essentially what
is being depicted in the dune series i
hope that helps explain it for you guys
thanks so much for watching make sure
you like and subscribe for more science
fiction lore just check out my channel
to find out all the series i cover
organized neatly into playlist